well listen man I got to give you props
the new album is out thank you it's I
got a bone to pick with you too it's a
mixtape why because
you call Freddie Gibbs album of the year
over months I think his album's better
than yours okay sure opinion I think you
got I think I got you around five
okay I put the list together the other
day okay you're about five so who's the
four before me I got Freddy Kendrick
Pusha T and jid and then Simba
that's disrespectful
you know what's disrespectful is the
songs you keep losing or leaving off
these [ __ ] projects no [ __ ] I
can't get [ __ ] cleared now you got this
[ __ ] it was a black Jesus oh yeah
that's the oldest song yeah that [ __ ]
should be honest that's crazy it'll come
soon let me tell you something but I
respect your opinion though you know
your mind no you're up there I put the
list together like literally what makes
what makes those albums better
I just think that they're I just think
they're better well I don't know what do
you want me to lie to you I was like
better because they're more like you're
friends with them no you're I'm closer
friends with you than everybody but
Freddy like I love you bro like I'm
waving your flag all the time I know I
wave your flag all the time I want to
put you I I they're deaf I'm not jid's
been on my show Once he's a nice guy
what makes j.i.d's album better than
mine I just think front to back it's
it's just I just think it's stronger
okay yeah but you don't have a reason
you just think I think jid's album
conceptually super crazy he's got a song
called Mom and them on there I just
think it's like to Me jid's album
and I think that the top three or four
albums of the year are all pretty close
yeah like some days I might feel like
it's pushed or some days I might feel
like it's Kendrick I think the top three
is like Freddy Kendrick uh push in any
order okay but then I think it's like
j-i-d it's you it's Denzel Curry uh Joey
Badass album
his album is dope uh Conway's album
Benny shout out to jid too I [ __ ] with
j.r.d though I just wanted also also
also your shit's a mixtape
yeah you had DJ Drama host it yeah but
what's a mixtape compared to album no I
agree I agree I'm just I'm just so I
would say that uh you are I just feel
like some [ __ ] got left off this project
no only thing that really got left was
it was a beat we couldn't get cleared
I would say this
I think that your album is great okay
and I think that you have some of the
more like dope relatable [ __ ] and I
think that
there are I think that some of the like
records I don't prefer on the album or
probably like the key Glock record
um hello there Rick
yeah I don't what I don't know I'm just
not crazy about it that's the record
does the Jeffrey dude on that record
yeah yeah yeah
but I didn't like that record um when
you played it for me before key Glock
was on it I like it I think it's a great
performance record it brings a lot of
energy the album is dope though no no
it's a great album I know I'm not saying
it's not I'm saying I'm trying to make
you like the song